hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the morphe
saga and last video we left it off
after the stunt and saga has finished uh
so the match never actually happened uh
and you know uh you know you you've
heard everything there was to hear
okay not everything you could hear a lot
more like i said if you guys want to
really dive into this
go grab lawson's book and you know
simply know everything about it
uh but you know in some uh short stories
you you've basically learned what
happened but now
uh we entered the match against the
champion of the old world
the the german uh or so well then the
prussian master adolf anderson
uh and it's uh it's simply one of the
greatest matches uh
in chess history but it was a problem
organizing this match as well not
because anderson
had a lot of terms like for example
staunton
but because morphe promised his family
that he would be back in the united
states in time for christmas
and um well there simply wasn't enough
time
they wrote to anderson and they asked
him if he would be able to
come to paris they wanted the match to
be held in paris and he said that he
would not be able to come
uh before some mid-december maybe
december 15th
and morphe did not have enough time to
travel to
to brussels where the match could have
taken place in the brussels chess club
uh so he said that unfortunately the
match will not happen but then
uh unlike uh unlike uh howard staunton
anderson himself wrote to morphe and he
said that it would be it would be a
crime against chess if that match didn't
happen
uh anderson did not have any terms he
didn't care for the stakes he said we
can play it for honor only you know it's
not a problem
uh but since you already came all this
way you know you you should definitely
face me
and morphy still was not convinced and
uh
uh well uh he was uh uh
a lot of uh not a lot of all the bigger
chess clubs in london and in paris wrote
to morphe that he should
uh reconsider that maybe he maybe maybe
he could skip christmas
with his family i don't think it was uh
uh morphy's uh
sort of thing to you know spend
christmas with his family i think it was
more of a family thing that they
requested this from morphe that he
be back for christmas uh but it seemed
very important and he was very
reluctant in uh you know denying them
this request but
everyone then wrote to morphy anderson
himself wrote the morphe everyone wanted
morphe to face anderson
uh you know they really tried everything
for for it to happen and then even
uh then morphe was not convinced he said
no unfortunately i will not be facing
anderson
uh i'm going back to uh to the united
states
uh but then uh morphy's doctor said that
uh morphy was too ill for the trip and
then he should
definitely postpone his trip at least at
least a month uh and
that was enough time uh for him to
accept the match with adolf anderson
uh and so morphe remained but um it was
not uh
a very enjoyable time in paris morphe
had an
intestinal influenza and well he was
being
leeched regularly so he lost a lot of
blood uh and he didn't
leave his room for two weeks so he was
very very weak
uh and even when anderson arrived in
paris he he came to morphy's room and he
you know saw in what condition morphe
was in and the match i think it was
friday and the match should
take place on a monday uh and morphy
said nope everything will be perfectly
fine
we're going to have the match it's it's
not a problem so uh
everything was arranged uh anderson came
to paris and uh you know
uh it seems that we we will have the the
greatest chess measured world has ever
seen
so far you know for for 1858 uh but
before
that uh okay anderson still had some
time he went sightseeing it was his
first
time in paris i believe uh and uh well
he met his
old friend harvicks and you all know uh
harvest if you've been following the
morphe saga so far
uh and the harvest has been saying to
everyone that he uh
well everyone knows he faced adult
anderson before but that he defeated him
and that he has a positive score against
anderson uh anderson denied this and he
said
that's simply not true but you are
welcome to
play me here and you know who whoever
wins wins uh they played a
match of six games anderson won three
harvests only won one and two
the two of the games were drawn so
anderson won that match very nicely
he also faced some of the local players
so and you know disposed of them uh
very easily so he was the more than
ready uh to face uh the the great paul
charles murphy even after
uh after his trip uh uh but like i said
he
he will face him uh only on monday uh
and monday
arrived and uh well anderson uh came to
the
uh to the game uh on time the the game
was agreed upon to be played at 12
o'clock
so uh you know uh in the afternoon
uh but morphe was late some half an hour
he still wasn't feeling all that great
and he was
they say that he was pale as a ghost
when he arrived to the game
uh but he still wished to continue the
match regardless of anything because it
uh consumed enough of his time and
everyone else's
and i guess he was also afraid that if
he was now
you know i guess he didn't want to
become the one who's postponing the
match now
after his trauma with howard staunton so
the match commenced
and as they say this game at the first
game of the match lasted for seven hours
but we're going to talk a little bit
more about this
uh so now let's dive straight into the
game this is the first game of the
legendary match
uh in paris 1858 paul charles murphy
versus out of anderson
uh as the title suggests the old versus
the new world so morphe
with the white pieces opens with e4
now let's see uh how anderson deals with
this we have e5
uh knight to f3 by morphe knight to c6
and
bishop to c4 anderson replies with
bishop to c5 and of course we all know
what morphy plays here that is of course
a b4 morphe goes for the evans gambit
uh and anderson not a stranger to the
airmen's gambit himself he
uh achieved many many great victories in
the evans gambit so of course he knows
how to play against the evans gambit
so bishop captures on b4 the best way to
play against it is to accept the gambit
with c3
and bishop to a5 now and morphe strikes
in the center with the d4 with e
captures on d4
and now morphe castle so this is all
very very standard stuff even by
modern standards uh and now knight to f6
uh going after the e4 pawn so morphe
advances it's the e5 attacks this knight
and anderson now shows that he's well
versed in the hidden arts of the evans
gambit as there is only one good move in
this position and that is of course d5
without this move
uh black's position simply uh falls
apart so here
you could trade captures captures not
that characters this captures uh but
morphy uh prefers to keep the the light
square bishop so bishop to b5
we have knight to e4 by anderson and now
c
captures on d4 and uh it's very
interesting you could also go for queen
to a4 but it's
it's kind of a droish line uh because
after bishop captures on c3 attacks the
rook we're gonna capture on c6 with
check b captures we're gonna capture the
knight knight captures attacks morphy's
queen
morphy captures with check bishop to d7
attacks the queen while also the queen
now defends the rook here
and after the queen moves and now we're
going to play queen to e7
and this is now perfectly fine uh for
for black and not
not a lot for for whites to look forward
to here you
you can trade queens you don't have
anything better than that
um capturing on c7 not all that great
bishop to b5 is coming and you don't you
don't really care about this i mean it's
uh
black was up in development and i mean
white played the evans gambit and of
course capturing the d4 pawn
uh runs into knights today to check and
you lose the queen
so it's not very ambitious but um
it's definitely the strongest move
morphy played c captures on v4 here
and it is now as of move 10 that this
position has never been reached again so
this is now
uh the original morphe versus anderson
first game uh we have castles by
anderson
in now as there's uh not all that much
to be done here morphe captures on c6
bishop characters b
captures and now queen to a4
attacking the bishop here and ready to
recollect the pawn here so anderson goes
back we have uh you you could also play
queen to c2 but
this kind of seems to be with tempo uh
so bishop to b6
and now queen captures on c6 morphe uh
grabs the pawn here
and now bishop to g4 it seems like
morphe is the one who's playing the
evans gambit but it feels like anderson
is the one that
uh you know forces morphy to to kind of
play his game because it's anderson
who's developing here
it's anderson who's attacking and look
at morphe uh the
well basically the king of rapid
development is you know
uh disregarding his peace development so
here
bishop to b2 even though the knight here
is attacked there is not a good way to
defend it you can play something like
knight beat to d2 to defend it because
this knight is needed
uh for guarding the d for pawn so here
we simply capture
and now you could capture with the
bishop and then we still mess up your
pawn structure and if you capture with
the knight
then of course you lose the d for pawn
and this pawn is kind of important
because now black has a past the d-pawn
so instead after bishop to g4 we have
bishop to beat you by morphy allowing
this capture because
yes you will bust open the king side but
he has some plans he's going to play
king h1
bring the rook to the g file and try to
attack anderson's king this way
so bishop captures an f3 g captures
attacks the knight and now
knight g5 with some ideas of maybe
capturing on f3
so knight to d2 morphy develops and the
defense
uh and now rook to e8 very interesting
is knight's the h3 check
because now the the king has to do
something it doesn't really matter what
the
king king g1 king h1 king g2 we're just
going to bring the queen to h4 and it's
a it's a very nice position for black
but understand first place rook to e8 he
says okay but why not bring the rook
into the attack as well so here we have
king to h1
morphy now or frees up the g1 square for
the rook but anderson does not allow it
knight to h3 uh we have f4 by morphy
and now saying okay are you maybe
interested in a pawn
but uh anderson not not the really fond
of any pawn grabbing uh
you know says no nope let's let's not go
for the pawn he says
queen the h4 now knight captures an f2
with
check definitely is an option uh and he
leaves uh the d5 pawn
uh free for for for capture so morphy
grabs the d5 pawn
again uh it seems like he's playing
anderson's game because
all of morphe's moves are basically
responses to anderson's moves
i know all the moves in chess are you
know responses to your opponent's moves
but here it's uh
well it just seems all very much forcing
so knight captures on f2 with
check morphy has to move the king king
g1 and now
you could go here for example to
threaten checkmate but knight f3
uh you know defense checkmate attacks
the black queen so it's not a problem
so after king g1 we have knight to d3
attacking the morphe's bishop on b2
and now we have bishop to c3 defending
uh well just moving the bishop out of
harm's way and now c5 is very
interesting here by anderson
trying to you know open up this diagonal
because the king
well is on the same diagonal as the dark
square bishop
but um instead of this we have knight
captures on f4 now it's not grabbing
upon now it's uh
it comes with a threat of just well the
queen is attacked and also we're
threatening 92 check to pick up the
bishop on c3
as the bishop is undefended so here
queen back to f3
and now comes knight the h3 check king
h1 and now knight g5 attacking morphy's
queen
and defending against queen captures an
f7 but but
by grabbing this pawn uh morphe also got
the adf file to be used for attacking
purposes
so queen back to g2 now if this diagonal
could open up then it will be great for
for morphe's attacks so rook eight to d8
bringing the last rook into the game
and now rook the g1 uh best for morphe
probably is knight to f3 just trade off
a pair of knights and uh well then you
know
we we we kind of go into this game
captures captures
uh we put some pressure on f7 so let's
say bishop captures on d4
morphy captures on f7 king h8 and now
you get this position even rook f4 can
be played attacking the queen and the
bishop
but then anderson would have this
beautiful queen captures an f4 no doubt
both of them saw this and that's why
morphe decided against the queen
captures
and now bishop captures some c bishop
captures on c3 attacking the rook and
the e5 pawn so you're not gonna even be
left with your with your past e
pawn and after the rook moves we're
going to pick up the e5 pawn
and it's uh well you're not winning this
with white but you might lose this with
white so
uh morphe decides against it so after
rook 8 28 we have rooked the g1 by
morphy
and now h6 anderson says all right how
are you ever going to move my knight
from here to deliver this checkmate
i i don't see it happening so rook a to
f1
morphy also brings his final rook into
the attack and now queen to h3
anderson says okay my position is better
i'm up upon let's trade queens
uh morphe not interested in this he goes
queen to c6 and
anderson offers a queen trade again
queen d7 we have queen back to g2
now uh h4 could be problematic if h4
comes but still knight to e6 will defend
the g7
so bishop captures on d4 grabbing
another pawn we have bishop captures
queen captures and now
knight to f3 now you cannot trade uh
then checkmate is definitely coming
and also the queen is under attack so
here uh we have queen to d5
uh with with uh a double attack on this
knight and
well you are probably going to play
something like rookie six rook to g6 and
then it's
just really really bad for white uh so
here morphy
could trade but it's uh i mean it's not
really a great position if you go knight
captures and g5 h captures any trade
queens
rook captures you could capture here but
then anderson captures here and you're
up two pawns in a rook and pawn end game
black black will win this so instead
after queen to d5 we have
h4 by morphy uh but now knight to e6 the
only square of course
that the defense checkmate so queen to
g4 morphine outland pins
tries to get the knight somehow into the
attack but now queen to c6 by anderson
uh we have rooked the g2 uh now uh
blocking this
uh diagonal so now the knight can move
it's no longer pinned and now
rook to d3 adding another attacker here
to the knight so rook to g1 is now not
possible we would simply capture the
knight
so queen to f5 by morphy and now uh
rook e to d8 this rook is attacked uh so
we have to be careful uh
anderson defends it uh and now what do
you play here well morphe could win a
pawn here he will play queen captures on
f7 it's possible but it's
it's still not a great position queen
captures king captures knight d4 opens
up a discovery here
rook to f3 this is the move that uh
uh anderson uh would have if this you
know happened because now
uh you can't really go uh here grabbing
the queen because we just captured the
rook with check so you would have to
capture the rook with the rook to
deliver check to the black king
then we give up the queen this way
knight captures and then for example
rook to d3
white black is up only one pawn but it's
such a uh
good position for black that there's no
playing this for white you can't move
the knight
because check picks up another pawn you
have to play a passive move like rook f2
then
we just play king g6 king h5 and you
know
it it basically plays by itself so
instead after rook e to d8 morphy plays
queen to f6 now saying okay you do have
pressure here but then i'm going to be
attacking your rook of course the queen
cannot be captured the rook here is
spinning the pawn
so queen back to d5 by anderson
again not a lot for morphy to do here we
have queen back to f5
and now rook to d1 offering a trade of
rooks so rook captures queen captures
with
check and now kink the h2 and now rook
to d3 anderson brings another attacker
to the knight here
uh so how do you defend morphy has to
play a passive move here rook to f2 but
it's not all that passive
if the knight ever moves then you're
going to have queen captures on f7
so rook the e3 now anderson wants to get
rid of this rook
because once this rook leaves the board
then he's just uh
you know up two pawns and there's not
all that much morphy can do
so morphy tries the very tricky knight
to d2 now kind of
saying okay i'm gonna capture on f7 but
anderson says you are more than welcome
to do that i'm just going to play rook
to e2
now attack your rook double attack on
the knight here you know
you can have your f7 pawn so morphy
grabs it there is really nothing better
queen captures on f7 king to h8 and now
knight to e4 offering the knight like
this so he can grab anderson's knight on
e6
anderson first captures the rook of
course the rook captures on f2 with
check knight captures on f2 and now
queen to d5
defending the knight uh we have knight
to g4
morphy finally gets his knight into the
attack but here
uh anderson plays a move that's
basically a slap in the face um
anderson plays a queen captures on a2
and uh
this comes with check but uh even even
if it didn't uh there's really no way
for
for morphe to utilize this knight uh you
know
for for the attack as you'll see king g3
queen b3 check king h2 we have queen
deceit you check
king g3 queen to c3 with check king h2
now comes queen to c6 and anderson says
you have nothing here there's nothing
you can play here i'm just gonna push my
past pawns and win the game
so morphe plays h5 he's gonna try to
sacrifice something that's for sure
i mean there's no other way to play this
we have a5 anderson simply starts
pushing his past pawn
and now knight to f6 threatening
checkmate
and uh anderson now needs to needs to
capture the knight so g captures an f6
and now queen captures an f6 if you play
this the kind of
you know it looks good because the pawns
are you know really really close to the
black king
uh the problem is the knight covers
these two squares uh the queen covers
this the king covers this so the white
queen really has no squares to do
anything here around the black king
so morphe instead plays queen captures
on f6 with chuck king g8
now queen g6 checking f8 he's gonna
capture on h6 with the check
king to e8 now another check on g6 king
to d7 and
now we have h6 uh now morphe also
ready to push his pass pawn to victory
uh and now there is
one move that wins the game for anderson
but it's not uh
easy as you may think so feel free to
pause the video
and try to find it the only winning move
for anderson uh while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
well really really difficult move and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
it is queen to f3 yep that's that's the
move
and uh it's not easy to realize why this
is the move but to give you an example
after h7 we're gonna play queen to f2
check and
after king h1 we're gonna play queen to
e1 with
check king to h2 and now we're gonna
pick up the e5 pawn with
check while guarding the queening square
and now okay we
we are back in the game and we can win
this game easily however
after h6 anderson did not find queen to
f3 he played queen to d5
and it seems like it's the it's pretty
much the same idea but it's not because
now
h7 uh well now h7
isn't good for morphe but morphy played
it and that that's the problem
uh the reason why queen to d5 isn't as
good as the move we discussed queen to
f3
is because here morphy could play queen
h7 check
kind of weird putting your queen in
front of your pass pawn but after
king to c6 now we play queen to c to
check and now the thing is if black
repeats
we're just going to deliver another
check and if he goes queen king to b7
now we play queen b
to check and now we deliver check while
defending our e5 pawn that's key and
after king a7 now h7 and now white has
white is definitely not losing this game
uh but after queen to d5 morphe played
h7 right away and this allows anderson
to pick up the e5 pawn with
check so queen captures on e5 king the
g1
and now knight to g5 another very tricky
move by
uh by anderson saying now okay there's
there's no move that you can play here
uh you can uh you know bring a queen
into the game and capture my knight but
still i'm i mean i
i i have two pawns uh but it's it's the
best morphe has so morphy played at h8
queen
uh we have queen captures and he got
grabs the knight on g5
we've queen to d4 with check before
starting to push the pawns of course
anderson
centralizes uh the queen king of king f1
and now a4
he starts pushing the pawn and now uh
morpheu of course will go for a series
of checks queen f5
check king to c6 now queen to c8
but it doesn't really help him all that
much king to b5 a beautiful move by
anderson
now saying okay if you capture on c7 i'm
just going to deliver check and of
course
the king and pawn end game is winning
for me because your king is outside
the square of the pawn king c1 a1 queen
black wins
so after king to b5 we have king to e1
now comes
c5 now the other pawn is being pushed
forward
we have queen to b7 with check king c4
queen to f7 with check king to c3 queen
to f3 with
check not just queen d3 now the problem
white can never trade queens because of
course black is the only one with pawns
queen to f6 check we have king to b3
queen to b6 with
check and now king to c2 again you
cannot capture here because
uh well we simply block check and force
a queen trade
that's winning for black so after king
to c2 we have queen to a7 by morphy
now queen to c3 check king to e2 and now
a3 our passport is nicely defended queen
a4 check we have king to b2 queen b5
check queen to b3
and he was in this position on move 72
that paul charles murphy resigned the
game
and the first game of the match goes to
the german master adolf anderson
so really an impressive game by by both
of them uh
i mean uh the evans gambit played to to
such perfection i mean it's really
really
just a joy to watch this and you know so
many things were happening in the game
even though the game lasted 72 moves
there was constantly something happening
and
uh well anderson even missed that one
move that allowed him to win the game
but morphy also missed his opportunity
to you know
bounce back and well it's it's such a
such a complicated game that you could
analyze it forever and you would always
find
very very good uh you know ideas for for
both sides
uh but yeah now first game of the match
goes to goes to anders and we'll see
what happens uh
in the uh in the other part of the match
and uh the only condition uh for the
matches of course that they play for no
stakes
the only stake is their honor that that
was agreed upon but it is first
the seven wins that's that's the
agreement so we're going to talk a
little bit more about
the match you know during this uh
anderson saga
but uh for this first game that's that's
it that's all the info you're getting
uh because some of you have been saying
that i'm giving out too much info but
that's why you have the little chapters
here you can click on it and skip the
info you can go straight into the game
uh but for those who are interested in
you know some history and you know
uh well basically the good stuff i i i
have to you know
say as much as possible so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank brandon fukuda
arnie cox uh mariah vhs.com and pedro
felix for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage
of the morphe saga until it ends thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your sunday